one of the things that i think slows us
down and i see slowing us down
is conversations where we say or a lot
so i like solar or wind
i like solar or natural gas with ccs i
like electric vehicles or i like
zero carbon cement you know whatever the
examples are i like one thing
we step back and we switch that to an
end conversation
this and this and this i'm for all these
things that get us to that goal
one of the things i think i learned
incredibly well at netpower
is listen we had some fantastic
scientists phds
out the wazoo probably too many of them
right what we what we
learned early on was that they weren't
the people to build
and to maintain and to operate right we
needed to build all that tint
big enough for all those people to be
under and leverage their expertise
because our smartest people had no idea
when it came to how to maintain pumps
and valves and compressors and
all of these other things that go into
maintaining a coal plant or maintaining
a steel plant
it gives us i think an opportunity to be
generous with each other again
to say we know we need to spend money we
know we need to try lots of stuff
we know one of us alone is not going to
do the job
so let's all work together and do this
incredibly important thing
[Music]
welcome back and on today's yang speaks
folks texas froze over the entire state
covered with snow and we need to talk
about this so we're going to continue
our limited series on the future of
and this is the future of energy
because when your most southern state or
one of your most southern states
known for its desert is covered in snow
you need to figure out why and what's
going to happen so here's what we did i
did something a little crazy
we're going to have three guests on this
episode at the same time
and i think it worked out pretty pretty
great actually um i think we avoided the
chaos that it could have been the three
guests i wanted to have on
covered three areas i wanted to cover
the science
the policy and health of this like the
healthcare piece of climate change
and energy and then the business
investment side so we have three guests
that cover each of these
the first one is dr julio friedman who
is a senior research scholar
at the center on global energy policy at
columbia university
he's an expert in carbon capture he used
to also work in governance he was a
principal deputy
i love these government titles principal
deputy assistant secretary of the office
of fossil energy
at the department of energy but he does
have a lot of doe department energy
experience
so i'm glad dr julia freeman's on second
guess is dr melissa lot
dr lot is an expert on
the healthcare side and healthcare
effects
of climate change so she's a senior
research scholar at columbia university
as well and works with dr freeman
and he was saying they're a perfect
compliment in terms of looking at both
sides and i agreed
and the last person we had on his doc is
not doctor david freed he's not a doctor
uh he's less cool just kidding david's
amazing he's an entrepreneur he's a
forbes 30 under 30 entrepreneur in
energy and he's i think 32 33 now and
he's already built a power plant
and that burns energy at a vastly
efficient rate
and is now worked in the investment side
private equity side
of clean energy and can talk about how
we need to get the private sector
involved in solving these problems so
you've got
david free dr melissa lott and dr julio
freeman
on this podcast it's fascinating we talk
about what happened texas talk about
what's going to happen
you're not going to want to miss it tune
in yang speaks
the future of energy
[Music]
alright folks welcome back to your
newest episode
of the future of and we are talking
about the future
of energy and there's an argument to be
made this is probably one of probably
the most important
future topic we'll bring on because if
we get this wrong
we're probably all toast or our if
you're talking about the impact of the
future on our humanity this one probably
hits the hardest
so joining us today we've got dr julio
friedman dr melissa lott in forbes 30
under 30.
let's call it an energy tech
entrepreneur david freed
um i'm excited for all three of you to
be here so welcome to yang speaks in the
future of energy welcome all
it's a treat to be here thanks for
having us 100
yeah thanks a lot zach so full
disclosure here while dr lot
is joining us she's joining us from her
car because
there's a snowstorm in austin texas
where you are is that
am i describing the situation correctly
yeah i think
uh last night we got a an inch or so of
ice
it was just spitting ice raining ice not
sleet raining ice pellets um and then it
got covered by about eight inches of
snow and
we were supposed to have a 40 minute
blackout and that was 13 hours ago and
counting so i'm
in the car that's where i'm at i
appreciate the
resilience here and the dedication to to
joining um
and frankly there's nothing more fitting
than being in texas
in a snowstorm um without power because
of this and
it's all the more reason we need to be
having these conversations thank you all
for joining
i want to dive in the meat of this so
the three of you i think are
three exceptional people to unpack
this question i have which i want to
talk about the energy problem and let's
call it
leads into the climate crisis we are
having today like let's level set
where we're at as a society right now
how bad is it what's going on
dr friedman let's let's start with you
if you wouldn't mind um
give us a little like a high level
overview of like our energy situation as
a country as a world
as we speak sure so
where we are right now is recognizing
how badly we've failed
and based on that uh marshalling for the
work ahead
and the good news is you know uh
the first step is acknowledgment you
know we have finally acknowledged
that we are not going to do what we
thought we could do in the time frame we
could do it so we simply need to do
more um there's lots of reasons
how to explain how we ended up here but
fundamentally
we now know that we have to go very far
and very fast
and we have to get to net zero in a word
the future of energy is net zero
if it's not net zero we failed because
we don't stabilize climate
ever as long as we keep emitting as long
as we keep adding to co2 in the
atmosphere
temperatures keep going up so we have to
get to net zero to stabilize at
any target and if we want to have that
stabilization happen
like with an ecosystem to go with it
then
we need to get there within a very short
amount of time
we need to get net to net zero somewhere
between 30
to 50 years depending on what fraction
of the global coral population you want
to die
so that's the setup and like that part's
not actually debated a whole lot
you're talking serious academia it's all
general consensus here
not only general academia most of the
governments in the world
most of the ceo and fortune 500
companies of the world
all agree to this what you do
is where everybody starts disagreeing
and
and there is no one answer to that but
there's a lot of things we
all generally know and that we accept
and
a lot of the discussion actually doesn't
start from the parts we agree on they
start from the
ends of the dumbbell where people
screech at each other but in fact
academia governments serious companies
generally agree on the foundational
elements as well
so the agreement and then this for you
dr locke i know you've done a lot of
work in
the human impact of this and
particularly in the healthcare side
the agreement is that we're melting the
planet is that what we've like
accepted and then if we don't do
anything we're essentially done
by 2050 20 100 years what's our
what are your thoughts on this and
what's our time frame there
yeah i mean the evidence is like if you
look at the data
you can try to look at it in the most
optimistic way possible but it is so
clear that climate change is already
happening it's already impacting our
health and it's just going to get worse
until we do something significant
and you know we've done little things in
different parts of the world
there's a little more ambition in some
countries less than others
but we are certainly not on track to
what we call minimize the health impacts
of climate change we're certainly not
on track to keep us to this target a lot
of people like to
talk about which is two degrees celsius
and forget the degrees for a minute the
exact degrees
don't matter so much the higher the
change in temperature the higher the
degrees the worse it is the more people
die the more people are sick
like the more natural disasters we have
the higher the number
the worse it gets and so our goal is to
keep it as low as possible to protect
ourselves and to protect our health
and so there's just a lot of consensus
around this when you look at the data
even if you want
to be optimistic and kind of you know
okay conservative number just look at
the bottom
it's still really bad still really bad
there's a lot of positive efforts in
this space like people are doing great
work
are we close to solving this or we need
to like pump the step on the gas pedal
to accelerate change
we need to massively accelerate what
we're doing that's also really clear
yeah so i'm not trying to diminish the
great stuff we've done we've got a lot
of corporations and governments stepping
up and saying we're going to change and
we're going to shift and same with
people you've got communities like the
city of des moines iowa just passed a
24 7 clean electricity standard for the
city they're like you know what we're
going to change this and this was just
weeks ago there's lots of good stuff
going on
but on right now i think the latest
numbers what julio were
3.7 degrees something like that 3.7 is
is awful we want well below two we want
you know going towards 1.5 so we're
not in a good place and until we make
some real shifts
we're not going to be on the path we
want to be on a good way to think about
it is if everybody did what they
promised under the paris agreement we'd
still be screwed
we would basically be at a 3 degree 3.2
degree world
if we did everything that we committed
to in paris
most people when they think about energy
they actually think about cars and
electricity
because that's what people see when they
think about energy they think about cars
they see cars they see electricity
they're like oh that's energy
that is not energy that's 40 percent of
energy
there's another 60 out there which is
trucks
ships planes steel making chemicals
cement and at
things like agriculture just like
putting fertilizing around the ground
adds to greenhouse gas load things like
deforestation
as the greenhouse gas loading so if we
electrified everything with zero carbon
electricity
and electrified all the cars massively
difficult super awesome i sincerely hope
we get there as quickly as possible
forty percent of the problem
when you say that three degrees celsius
number that we're tracking towards
when is that right is that 20 years is
that 100
like and frankly i think that's one of
the challenges we have is that the
average humans like oh that's 100 years
from now that's 200 years from now we'll
be fine we'll be smart enough then
what's the timing i mean we're talking
when we talk about average temperature
rise we're talking about the end of the
century but when we talk about the
health impacts we actually are
quantifying what's happening right now
so something is interesting we just did
a bunch of analysis around it but bottom
line is
if we meet paris agreement targets or if
we meet this net zero culio's talking
about so if we actually
put the pedal down on the you know the
gas as it were that would be something
other than gas
um you know we're talking about
something like 8 million
at least lives a year that that will be
saved
versus lost in 2040 just off of a couple
of the different health effects just off
of the small ones
um so that's i mean it's millions of
lives every single year
that we will be losing starting at the
middle of the century so hopefully if
i'm lucky you know
in a time when i will still be here um
and our kids will certainly still be
[Music]
here
all right new sponsor alert i want to
tell you guys about parachute
because parachute essentially their goal
is to make people feel at home
and their their let's call it tagline is
making home your happy place and i just
got my sheets
and towels and a bathrobe from parachute
and i promise you they are making my
home a happy place
they are so comfortable it's like lying
on a cloud i don't know how to explain
it
it's like soft and beautiful and warm
and fuzzy and i promise you it's
freaking
amazing and i literally this is so
stupid but i look forward to taking a
shower because
i get to wrap myself in those freaking
towels it's like butter i'll explain it
it's amazing so make home your happy
place check out parachute home they have
like it's not just towels they've got
rugs they've got all this in-home
softness i don't know how to explain it
but you have to check it out so
parachute
home dot com so parachute like the thing
you use and jump out airplanes parachute
home
dot com slash yang you get free shipping
free returns you can try it out
parachutes very comfortable premium
quality home
essentials you're gonna love it check it
[Music]
out
david you worked for
a startup clean clean tech firm or in
the private sector in like terms of
building and then went more into like
the investing side
like bigger picture frankly what are you
seeing from the private sector side of
things
yeah so i think and i think covet helped
to frame a lot of this discussion
because i think pre-covid
you know was a lot of corporations were
when covet hit corporations said hey
what is it that we weren't paying
attention to that could drastically
impact our future
right and and i think there's a classic
video that bill gates is talking about a
couple years ago at ted where he's like
hey
something like covid could be a
multi-trillion dollar problem and
everyone just said hey that's bill gates
talking right
but then covet hits and it's like oh my
god he was right times a couple
right and it's and i think now you think
you see with like
for example ceo of blackrock right larry
fink
seven trillion dollar asset manager says
last year
number one our strategy is climate right
because i think
and when you're that big every ceo is
paying attention
and it's and it's mattering right
because like you're seeing
you look at like the impact of esg funds
in this past year
right there's now over 500 esg funds you
can invest in
as for us index funds right where
they're focused on
climate solutions and esg for those it's
environmental social governance some
would call it green investing depending
on your slices but you look at
looking at let's call it climate impact
or
the governance upside and the societal
impact as an investment risk
correct and and i would say you know so
i've kind of lived it on the ground
at a startup trying to build and now i'm
seeing it a little bit more from the
investment side
and i think where i get excited is these
problems this problem is a massive
problem
and we should be very scared at the same
time this is also the
i think the biggest value creation
opportunity in our lifetimes
right and i think that certain countries
get that i think china understands that
right they are building uh electric cars
and vehicles
electric vehicles and batteries at a
rate that's out
outpacing the united states right now
and you see i think a lot of these
people like
larry fink are saying this not because
they
they inherently just care about the
environment even though they may
but because they see enormous
opportunity to pivot the entire economy
into new areas of growth right and we
have in a world where we have almost
no growth right where you got to look
for what those big pockets are growth
and when there's this much structural
change as as dr friedman said of
it doesn't matter the sector they use
energy right
if you think about that structural
change that means that change is going
to mean
entrepreneurs creating new businesses i
mean think about tesla right
multi-trillion dollar business
over a trillion dollar business created
to address one issue related to climate
change but think about the size of
energy and everything that it touches
for me i get really excited about yes we
can work on the problem
but the way that you get people really
motivated and
in in in this becomes sticky is by
allowing them to be entrepreneurs in the
space so that
there's so much unpack there and i agree
with you so having worked
for a large company for about 10 years
the the takeaway was
they're going to do what it impacts
their bottom line there might be some
altruistic ceos that
are committed they're good humans trying
their best but they get fired if they
don't
hit their quarterly profits and things
like that so the best thing on the
corporate side of things feels like
green is good right where the green is
greedy or however you want to say that
where there's financial incentive
to lower energy costs and lower carbon
emissions
um i want to unpack that in a second but
also i think dr freeman a good place to
start just on the counter to start
you've worked in government before it
what have you seen from a government
response that'll actually accelerate
this are there ways they can incentivize
the companies david's talking about to
actually start accelerating this
oh there's an enormous amount that
governments can do and thankfully
governments are starting to get serious
about that that's probably the better
question what are they doing now to
start
well but that's the thing like they're
starting to get serious they're not
quite serious yet
but they're starting to get serious
right let's start with the fact that all
the government money in the world isn't
enough for this problem
we need a lot of private money in the
mix as well
so as in the democratic primary last
year we had some people saying two
trillion dollars a year and some people
saying 10 trillion dollars a year like
it's
actually still not enough money like we
need we need money from the private
sector to make this win
so what the biggest possible role for
the government is to craft
market aligning strategies market
aligning policies
so as an example of a couple of market
aligning strategies that were successful
in the united states we had renewable
portfolio standards
we had the solar investment tax credit
we had the wind production tax credit
very recently we've had 45q for carbon
capture and storage
in germany we had the energy vendor
which was a bunch of feed-in tariffs for
renewables
combined with the european trading
system in china there was a bunch of
mandates where they just said we're
going to
a hundred thousand megawatts of wind
we're gonna build a hundred thousand
megawatts of solar they just
like every system is different but but
they actually put their shoulder into it
and say we're gonna craft
policies that the market values
so once a company realizes it can make
money in the system then they start
doing it
right that is that is actually the core
of the business because there's only
three sources of money in the world
there's rate payers there's taxpayers
and there's shareholders
and there's not enough taxpayer money
and there's not enough shareholder money
so you need the rate payers you need
customers around the world
to start putting the money into this and
that means they need to get a return
you listed off a ton of things there
what's working the best i get you know i
guess someone say like i feel like the
lowest common denominator probably has
to happen globally
so this is the thing there is no one
answer to that
every government gets to choose its own
thing and make it work so for example
one can argue that a really positive
potent strategy
in canada is they've just announced 170
carbon tax
that's gonna do a lot right
that will that will stimulate a lot of
investment in canada
no doubt about it like but the and that
will include government matching grants
and
so forth that will include big oil
companies
and big insurance companies and pension
funds putting money to work like all
that stuff's going to happen
that's just a regulatory pathway there's
no incentive of any kind
but it does the job you have to be big
binding and down
and as long as you do that it's good
enough
and that can be in the form of an
incentive or it can be in the form of a
disincentive
either way though one country doing it
isn't enough either
we need lots of countries doing it but
one of the things that
i find frustrating as many people forget
that russia exists
and so if we stop selling oil in the u.s
they just pick up the market
that doesn't exactly solve the problem
right
and china exists they make half the
steel in the world and half the cement
in the world
and have three quarters of the
coal-fired power plants so if we don't
get china on board we're not exactly
going to fix this problem
so it's it's thorny and complicated in a
lot of ways but fundamentally
you have to step up in a big market
aligning policy
and whatever that big market aligning
policy is people can disagree on
but you still need that flavor of things
it's one of the things andrew used to
say on the trail
when we were running for president he'd
say look if if u.s went to
if the united states went to energy you
know zero
in terms of emissions it wouldn't do
anything it wouldn't because we're not
enough of the i mean would be better
than nothing of course
um and generally helpful but it wouldn't
stop
what we're trying to fight against it's
a global issue
[Music]
all right yang speaks is brought to you
by athletic greens
this is the most comprehensive daily
nutritional beverage i've ever tried i'm
not the best at eating well and in covid
if you're ordering like
your habits are all like you don't
really have the right routine and
athletic greens can help just making
sure you get all the veggies and all the
vitamins and all the things you're
supposed to have
in a balanced diet so one scoop of
athletic greens got 17 vitamins minerals
whole food source ingredients it's got a
multivitamin a multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blends like one of those
green smoothies and oil powder
it's awesome and they work together to
fill the nutritional gaps in your diet
increases your energy get a little more
focus all these good things so
you guys need to check this out go to
athleticgreens.com
yang and join health experts athletes
and health conscious go-getters around
the world to make a daily commitment to
their health every day
and athletic greens is doubling down on
supporting your immune system during the
winter months
they're offering our audience a free
one-year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase if you visit our link
today so you never have to buy vitamin d
again it's amazing so that's
athleticgreens.com slash yang get your
free supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs today
[Music]
dr la i'm so fat so i read your paper
and
i just want to say for those listening
guys i never read academic papers and i
i read this and i was um that's what
it's worth i'll put the link in in this
episode um
but what blew my mind is when we talk
about climate change we always talk
about
a lot of stuff we just talked about dr
freeman like these big kind of this is
where we're going we're melting the
planet the temperatures are rising the
sea levels rising this anything but what
you
and your colleagues talk about is like
hey this is going to get really bad in
the short term
too because you highlight the human cost
where people start getting more asthma
people start having to move to certain
places
there's health care systems start to get
stressed like there's
the lack of communication from
governments all these different things
so tell us about
a little about the human impact here and
i'm curious like
i i guess like the big takeaways that
you see from from
your paper and your research that starts
to impact humanity quickly
yeah i mean i think the biggest thing is
that i
this isn't something that is going to
happen in the future it is already
happening now like we are already
getting sick now so we're already seeing
that you know 300
000 people around the world in 2018 like
um
you know died because of heat related
stress that like wasn't there before
like i mean these are these are hundreds
of thousands of people over the age of
65 in this case that it's like
very conservatively we can say they died
because of these
increasing heat waves that we're having
and also like people aren't able to work
and we saw this in like the
you know the valley and in california
and the south and stuff
over the last summer where it was huge
heat waves and people just were like i
literally my body cannot function in
this situation like this is affecting me
today
and sure the challenges are in other
countries but as well
but we're seeing them in the united
states the other thing that has struck
me in all the research is that the
benefits we have from moving
to these cleaner sources of energy and
moving the whole system we feel them
today so as you say it's like less kids
with asthma
like kids the number of kids that are
getting asthma is completely
mind-blowing and you can trace so much
of it back to air pollution
that's coming from the same energy
resources that are putting greenhouse
gases in the air
so you're like let's actually take that
away and then people who've never smoked
getting lung cancer and you're like why
on earth is this happening
air pollution from the same sources so i
think the biggest things that i see is
like in the research you know we've had
to double check our numbers like you
know
dozens of times to make sure we're right
on point around the fact that
even if you ignore all this climate
change business moving to cleaner
sources of energy pays for itself
through the health benefits that we feel
now not that i will feel in the future
the things i'm not going to experience
and in the us the actions we take will
help the world
but they will pay for themselves at home
i don't even have to look across borders
to get the payback
but we're just not choosing to actually
go down that path at least not as
quickly as we can i'll say like the
incoming administration
in dc is certainly signaling that they
want to change that
there's a lot of cities and states that
are signaling they want to change that
but we need more action
faster better it's like okay great on to
the next thing we need to be more
aggressive and more aggressive if we're
going to realize these health benefits
that's the thing it it gets my heart
when i read about you know that
grandmother who didn't live that extra
15 years of her life or that kid who got
asthma
who never should have had it like that
there was a way to prevent it
we talk about this so much when we talk
about like eliminating poverty and that
we do these
me do these initiatives and programs
that are supposed to
either save money or like there's
certain things you save money for the
government or save money for businesses
but we
pay for it on the back end ten times
over right so
um it's fun i just loved reading your
piece um in your research because that's
you're i hadn't thought about that from
a climate change perspective but it
makes so much sense
in that lens what else can we do in
terms of solutions
people need to recognize that we can
and should combine a construction agenda
with a reduction agenda
if we don't do both of those things
we're going nowhere okay
so we cannot build our way to zero we
cannot just add stuff to the energy
system
and expect that's gonna work but also if
we just shut stuff down that is not
equitable that does not create wealth
like we can't get there doing
either of those things alone we have to
combine a construction agenda with a
reduction agenda
i it's helpful and it focuses the mind
to start talking about things that are
outside of everybody's day-to-day
experience thinking about this and my
favorite example is steel
okay steel is nine percent of global
emissions
if you don't fix steel you don't fix
anything okay
so you gotta get there most people don't
go to the store and buy a hundred
thousand tons of steel so don't think
about the energy that's in steel
but like it emits more than cars for
every ton of steel you emit three tons
of carbon dioxide
and the math is any process that starts
with melting rocks
uses a lot of energy so if you got to
melt the rock
you're using a lot of energy the recipe
for sand is you melt
sorry the recipe for glass is you melt
sand and pour it on liquid tin
it just uses a lot of energy okay so
steel is the same thing but the other
thing
is you're actually chemically changing
an iron ore to iron and iron oxide to
iron to do that
you add what's called a reducing agent
that releases co2 in most systems
so the blast furnace puts out a ton and
a half of co2 that's just the chemistry
of making iron
it's completely independent of the fact
that you're melting the rocks
so you just put out a ton of emissions
every time you do this and there's not a
lot of substitutes for that
so the question is how do you combine a
con this thing i talked about a
construction agenda with a reduction
agenda
and some of the work that we're doing
suggests that the best thing to do is
actually replace the whole plant
that the way the plants were built will
continue to emit you can capture
say fifty percent of it you can maybe
get seven percent more by electrifying
stuff
you can maybe get another twenty percent
by adding biomass but you can't actually
get to zero and we need to get to zero
you have to replace the existing
facility with a different kind of
facility
say direct reduction of iron which can
get to zero
and we have those technologies and
they're in the field today
governments need to think about that
what policies do they put in place
to tell the guy who runs a steel mill in
gary indiana we want to replace your
plant as opposed to we want to shut it
down
that's a pretty different thinking and
so somebody's building something we're
making stuff in this country
but we're zeroing out the emissions at
the same time you know i
i can't but like you said i can't buy a
thousand tons of steel at my grocery
store
right but i can go buy products that
have sustainable
uh either goods going into them or
sustainable packaging or compost
compostable packaging
or plant-based packaging and if we think
about and i think consumers are doing
this i mean they are doing it like
2013 to 2018 50 half of all growth
in new cpg products was from sustainable
products
right so like one of every two products
was sustainable and now
you guess what you see unilever pepsi
all these big guys are saying hey we're
gonna get to net zero by 2040
right because they recognize that
consumers are voting with their dollars
and i think it goes back to what julio
was saying
which is you know rate payers ultimately
are going to help to dictate a lot of
this action
and by doing that the governments are
going to listen corporations are going
to listen and we're going to move things
there now
i think government has to move things
faster in order to
overcome some of the challenges that we
saw when we were building that power i
think
you know with with net power um you know
our idea was how
the rest of the world is going to build
coal and natural gas how do we get that
to zero still
right and you look at india and china
they're putting in indonesia and
southeast asia i mean the amount of coal
and natural gas going on the ground is
is terrifying um and so we can hope that
everybody moves to renewables and
batteries but as julio is described
it doesn't get us all the way in and of
itself we need a carbon capture solution
for everything else not to mention power
generation
and frankly you know the we had
international governments that were more
supportive
of domestic governments at times and it
took time for international for domestic
to catch up to where europe was
and for the entrepreneur that's trying
to build this i mean tesla doesn't get
to where it is today without
the support by the obama administration
and now they're
feeding a ton of money back into the
system that naturally pays for that
itself and i think government
helps to support that acceleration of
the build
i don't think anybody on this call and
you know melissa who can correct me
we're not suggesting that we want to all
go live in bunkers like that's not the
goal to solve climate change
right the goal to solve climate change
is enhance our standard of living
while getting to zero and by doing that
we need all minds right
minds engineers we need business people
we need scientists
to solve some of these problems with
novel solutions that allows us to factor
sustainability into the solution
without being unrealistic about what's
going to happen
there's an important point in here like
we actually know how to do
a lot of stuff to make our lives better
very quickly like we know how to replace
a lot of the
power you know plants in this country
and around the world with cleaner
technologies like we know how to do a
lot of stuff there is still a percentage
of the whole system that we don't
know what to do with so like innovation
is important but i think people maybe
overstate how much more innovation how
much more cost reductions we need
like in many cases i'm a phd engineer
all right but i work in a policy shop
because the technical challenges are so
often not
what is actually keeping things from
happening that's not the problem
it's not the technology it's not the
cost it's like not having a policy in
place that actually rewards something
for something very good it's doing
not allowing something to get into the
system like it's
not allowing a customer to actually get
what they want i mean i
the number of stories i can tell you
about someone who said you know what
i've saved up and i want to put some of
these new cheaper solar panels on my
place
and i've got everything done and the
utility won't let me tie in because they
don't have
rules of the road around this and i
don't know what to do and they're
telling me i've got to like
go off grid or not have solar you know
so i'm going to give up because i got 50
other things to do with my day
like these types of things are the
things we need to solve as well while
we're looking at that last get to zero
you know last 10 or more you know we can
talk about that too but i think it's a
really important point there
there's a lot we can do right away we
have to segregate
innovation and deployment right like we
have to walk and chew gum
we have to do both right and like it's
not going to be that
some magic technology is going to enable
us to all of a sudden get to net zero
overnight that's not going to happen
although that's what the
the idiots like me are hoping for we're
actually all hoping for smart people
everybody wants the secret diet pill but
yeah
right but reality gets you in the way
right and so i would say like
we need to focus on large-scale
deployment at acrop globally right and
how to enhance that
in our businesses in our company in our
in our communities
in our countries that's critical right
innovation economy
i think will feed a lot of those
large-scale deployments
if we get the policy right up here
innovation entrepreneurs i think will
meet that challenge and have already met
that challenge because a lot of people
have seen this
coming for i don't know 20 30 40 years
or more
and so i totally agree with melissa you
know the silver bullet here is never
going to be the answer
there's a lot we can do with technology
we have today and should be doing and
are doing some
but not enough and i think that's our
opportunity is to work through
all of those all those challenges
because when you do i think there's a
huge value creation on the other side of
[Music]
that
are you losing your mind because i am in
covid i
am a little more stressed i'm a little
more short-tempered
i sometimes just want to bang my head
against a wall i feel lethargic
and right now it's really helpful to
talk to somebody and that's why i want
to talk to you guys about better help
better help is a way to connect with
someone to talk to
in a safe and private online environment
it's super convenient you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's not
a crisis line it's not even self-help
really it's just professional
counseling done securely online so you
can send a message to your counselor any
time
you get these timely thoughtful
responses and schedule weekly phone or
video sessions and so you can specialize
and talk to specialists in depression
stress anxiety relationships sleeping
grief all of it
i've been doing it's great keeps me sane
i love it so
i want you to start living a happier
life today and as a listener you're
going to get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor
betterhelp.com yang that's
betterhelphelp.com join over
one million people have taken charge
their mental health like us
betterhelp.com
[Music]
there's a temptation to start drawing
axes of contention where there aren't
any
most people agree that we need to deploy
what we have today and innovate
like there's not actually a lot of
debate around that so it's not an either
or conversation really
some people think we should do more
innovation some people think we should
do more deployment but
you know you can still plow a field with
a russian tractor it does the job
there's stuff you can do today
and you would ultimately like to be able
to plow a field with something a little
smarter
somewhere down the line so like we and
we know that innovation reduces risks
reduces costs
makes it easier for policy makers to get
to yes but the most
important thing that people can do on
their own
is learn first care
second in that order they need to learn
first
and care a second most people think
electricity comes from the wall
they don't know that it comes from power
plants around the country
they don't know what a power plant is or
how it works they don't know how power
markets work right
so they just scream fix it without
learning
that's not helpful because in fact these
things are complicated and require some
knowledge and expertise
similarly once they start caring good
things happen
they elect people who care for example
which is important to get the policies
through that
similarly if enough people in the market
said hey gm
we want a low carbon car then gm can
start procuring low carbon steel
because to zero out the emissions from
steel cost a whole lot to the steel
maker
but to the person buying a car it adds
two percent to the car
it doesn't really make a difference to
the ticket price
but gm is not going to disadvantage
themselves in their market they're not
going to pay more for steel
until the customers ask for it and and
putting a carbon content label on the
card doesn't do the job either
like they need you you need to get
people to learn enough that they can
care and ask for things that matter in
policy in markets
and and that is true in materials that
is true
in energy so this is this is a
fascinating
question um or point you're making so i
have this theory that
all of our problems actually stem from
education when you don't educate your
populace the right way
eventual bad things happen particularly
in a democracy
this is a weird question but i'm so
curious your thoughts
is one of the best policies we could
actually do is start teaching this more
clearly
in grade school in high school at a
public level like with the if you're
talking about a 10 20 30 year timeline
or so
a it's too late for that and and b al
already
people are starting to care and that's
good enough like like
we're getting there's more caring and
more learning that needs to be happening
but i don't need to be a doctor to start
learning about my health and caring
about my health right we don't need to
make a world of experts
we need to make a world of people who
know enough to care about the right
things
and uh in that context you know this is
actually melissa's strong suit like she
she she understands this stuff deeper
than i do and that's probably the
question for you dr lot is
if we're going to start learning how do
we do that
um particularly in the attention economy
today where you're not just competing
against
other ideas which is competitive enough
let's say you're competing against kim
kardashian and instagram and whatever's
on facebook today like how do you get
people to learn
actually learn about this yeah i mean
one of the big things that we look at in
the work that we do for the lancet which
is a medical journal is how do people
get information
how do they first get exposed to this
link between climate change and health
and the fact that like climate change is
impacting your health now and then
the same sources of greenhouse gases are
the same sources of pollution that's
giving your kid asthma like how do you
make all these connections
and so you know there's a whole group of
folks led by a woman named hillary
graham who like say okay
the reality is people google for things
that are about their health
and then they link into information
about climate change like that's the
direction it is
very few you know very small percentage
of the time does it go the other way
where they're looking at climate change
stuff and they get into the health stuff
it happens but the bubbles are big on
the health side of things
so for us i mean that's one of our big
opportunities where we say like look
a lot of us most of us go to the doctor
at some point
doctors are treating the effects of
climate change so let's help
doctors to understand so let's educate
what not this blanket you know of course
we want everyone to understand
but like a doctor is trying to treat the
symptoms instead of the root cause let's
show them what the tools are for the
root cause and i'll tell you like we
have a huge group of doctors that is now
taking
the analysis we do and using it
to say we want different policies we
want to reduce our own emissions
footprints health care systems are five
percent of global greenhouse gas
emissions
five percent so they're like this is
something i can control now
and so we're going to demand it so
you've got things like in the uk where
their national health care system is
going to net zero
like you've got commitments like this
you've got a whole program and a vale um
led by a woman named jody sherman who's
like looking at this and saying what can
we do today in american hospitals to
have the outcomes improved so we're
healthier over time treatments are still
getting better
but we're not actually on the back end
of that getting better in the short term
making people sick both in the short and
the longer term
like how can we do that so i think
education i think this actually comes
back to a point that sums up a lot of
what we're talking about right now
one of the things that i think slows us
down and i see slowing us down
is conversations where we say or a lot
so i like solar or
wind i like solar or natural gas with
ccs i like electric vehicles or
i like zero carbon cement you know
whatever the examples are i like one
thing
we step back and we switch that to an
end conversation
and we say okay what is the goal the
goal is reducing emissions the goal is
to be healthy and to be healthier over
time and to not undermine our health by
letting climate change and air pollution
all the other stuff that comes with it
get us to be sicker over time so this
and this
and this i'm for all these things that
get us to that goal the goal is not the
technology
that's not the point the goal is to
reduce emissions and make us healthier
theoretically i'd like to not worry
about this you know or like it's baked
into the fabric of society
where we're all totally keeping the plan
in front of mine right david have you
seen this
actually this is really curious when the
for-profit side of things david that
you have companies they're starting to
care now because it affects their bottom
line right or it can or they see that
the dollar signs which i'd argue is a
good thing but are they learning
right or is there like is there a
learning on the investment side and it's
a weird question but i am curious with
that
no it's a good i think it's a good
question i i think yes they're being
forced to learn
i think you have pension funds which are
asking the big
asset managers to care and so then they
have to hire consultants to help them
care
to help them learn and i think you know
i had a really smart
uh asset manager tell me he said you
know environmental feels like
playing defense playing offense and
being efficient
so defense is around how do i how do i
reduce my risk right how do i make sure
that i don't have runoff issues or
long-term supersite issues that are bank
could bankrupt my company
right that's that's like uh huge risks
huge tail risk for these businesses
efficiency is that makes money today
right like companies you go put in leds
you make money today your payback is two
three years
at bet like in the worst case if you
have old lighting
you replace new hvac you do you know you
upgrade some
some of your vehicles from gas guzzlers
to hybrids like
you make money you make money today
right you reduce your waste you make
money today right and that's so that's
being more efficient with resources you
have
and then offense is how do i ensure that
i'm positioning the companies for growth
in this new economy right so how do i
build sustainability into my product
line
how do i position myself with customers
and with investors
how do i ensure that my employees are
engaged on sustainability issues because
our generation cares a ton about this
issue and in order to
you know retain people it's a huge huge
issue right and so
i really like that framing you know i
can't take credit for it but i really
like that framing to say am i going to
lose a ton of money as a result of not
doing something
how do i how do i operate within the
bounds of what i already do today
and then how do i position myself for
growth i think those are great questions
regardless of the size of business you
can ask yourself
this takes me back to where i started
with the future of energy is net zero
and so a whole bunch of companies figure
that out enough
to make declarations they're like we're
gonna go to net zero and then they turn
around to their staff and say tell me
how to get there
and actually wrote a blog piece on this
it's posted on the carbon direct website
and they turn around and their whole
staff goes we don't know
we can't get to zero and i've had the
good fortune of working
with microsoft on on their announced
goals they're going to get to net zero
by 2030 it's incredibly ambitious
and they have they emit 16 million tons
a year
that's pretty small for a company
microsoft side but their software
company okay 16 million tons
they know how to get all the way down to
six so if they do everything they know
how to do they can get rid of two thirds
of their emissions and a third or left
and then they're like oh crap well how
do we get to zero let's say they
innovate
like mad and they invest in a whole
bunch of bad scientist stuff that
doesn't exist and get another
two million tons down they're still at
four million tons they've only gotten
rid of three quarters of their emissions
they still got a quarter left
and they got nothing for that zero
the future is zero and zero's hard
and in that context we have to try
things
that we haven't tried yes we need to
plant trees but we also need to do
things like direct air capture
and we can't leave anyone off the field
to melissa's point we can't just say
well i like solar that's enough it's
like no it's clearly not
it's like and the most sophisticated
companies
have already acknowledged that and now
they're scrambling to try to put
together a plan for their net zero
commitments
because they know they have to get there
like like david said that is offense and
defense and efficiency all at the same
time
like they're all doing those things and
they still can't get to zero
so we need to be generous with each
other as we build this world
we need to be creative we need to be
open-minded we need to
have innovation in business every bit as
much as we need innovation and
technology
and every much as we need innovation and
law and policy we it's a
l hands on deck to get to net zero
and the companies are beginning to
understand that and they are learning
to the point that now they can think
about what to care about one thing that
is great about the zero point is it
gives us clarity in the discussion
though
like we're not splitting hairs or if
it's 75 or 80
or you know 60 by insert a years insert
your favorite you're here
the goal is zero everything is driving
to zero that is where we're headed
and it gives us a clarity in the
conversation and i'll say to david's
point like
i remember we created a great video game
about a decade ago
12 years ago that was called uh wyville
with wypower you could operate your own
power plants and grid super cool
what you learned from that is that kids
at that time who are now in their 20s
are environmentalists at least in the us
but also in the global people that
played that game they're
environmentalists
that's it they saw the oceans acidifying
they saw the air getting polluted
they didn't care about the bottom line
they were like no how do i do this and
how do i do it cost effectively but i
feel like this is some
this is a pressure that is under
acknowledged is the consumer desire and
the growing consumer desire for these
things
i want to highlight another kind of
undercurrent that i don't hear talked
about enough
and i think it's appropriate because
i've heard you know when i hear andrew
yang talk about this
he talks about the equitability of
automation right is the story of the 90s
and 2000s i think
uh julia brought up the point of
equitability of of this energy
transition right and you have a lot of
communities out there that
it takes a lot it creates a lot of jobs
for maintaining legacy
systems right and and often these
communities are out
you know typically rural right power
plants tend to be out in
in the middle of the country and those
are really nice paying jobs
and i think you have we have to build a
community that see that sees the future
of the energy transition
as positive for them not just because
listen the environment the environmental
and the health benefits are absolutely
important and should justify it and of
itself but people still want to go to
work and get paid and use their skills
and one of the things i think i learned
incredibly well at netpower is listen we
had some fantastic scientists phds
out the wazoo probably too many of them
right what we
what we learned early on was that they
weren't the people to build
and to maintain and to operate right we
needed to build
all that tint big enough for all those
people to be under and leverage their
expertise
because our smartest people had no idea
when it came to how to maintain pumps
and valves and compressors and
all of these other things that go into
maintaining a coal plant or maintaining
a steel plant
or maintaining a fertilizer plant and i
think that that conversation is one that
policy has to be a part of and companies
have to be a part of but we can't forget
in this conversation
the news has gone sideways in many ways
and it's one of the reasons i like the
new yorker
in print and online the new yorker kind
of stands apart because commitment to
truth and accuracy and it's got really
quality writing compelling reporting and
storytelling and i love it because it's
not always politics
so they've got weekly print but they've
got daily online articles that cover
this full range of topics so not just
politics but there's news international
fair climate change
the environment pop culture arts fiction
food humor cartoons you name it one
article i was reading was
on an unethical ai which i am fascinated
by and i want to cover on here this guy
matthew hudson wrote a pretty
fascinating piece on what ai
could look like down the road so i want
you guys to check this out so for a
limited time you can get 12 weeks of the
new yorker for literally six bucks
that's a savings of 50 percent they're
giving you a big discount because you're
listening to yang speaks
plus listeners of the show get an
exclusive tote bag for free
can't get anywhere else right here so go
to newyorker.com
yang that's n-e-w-y-o-r-k-e-r
dot com slash yang to get 12 weeks in
the new yorker for just
six dollars and you get a free tote bag
carry it around
so newyorker.com
[Music]
is there anything that's exciting you
down the road that could work that could
start to solve this that we could get
excited about
oh god the last the list is so long i
mean i honestly think some of the most
exciting stuff is stuff that i can see
each of us adopting in our lives as
opposed to these kind of
far out of reach no offense i don't have
a lot of say over that steel production
facility
in my own daily life so like utilities
letting me
check a box and say that i want 100 of
my electricity to come from zero carbon
resources
like i check a box i forget about it the
next month and i have done
something meaningful that is measurable
like it sounds so boring but that means
it's exciting and you know what not
not even everywhere in this country but
certainly not around the world that's
not just a default option you can pick
what i'll say is in this whole
transition i know julio you've got lots
of great thoughts about tech
we have an opportunity to either
exacerbate equity gaps make them worse
or narrow them and really intentional
steps forward can narrow them we know
where a power plan is the lucky thing
about it is they don't have feet and
they don't run around
you know we know where it's going to be
we know the community that will be
impacted we know the makeup of that
community
like we can do things very intentionally
we won't do that if we don't think about
it
um but julio you you have the rundown on
the cool tech so i'm going to pitch it
over to you
there's two things that i'm super
excited about uh and i'm gonna start
with with the most
obvious and nearest term one which is
hydrogen uh
hydrogen is gonna be a big honking thing
and the nice thing about hydrogen is
there's no pollution with it
none when you consume hydrogen it turns
into water and that's it it either makes
heat or it makes electricity and either
way the byproducts water
okay so if you make the hydrogen with a
low carbon footprint
you can do a lot and and it's the swiss
army knife of decarbonization
it goes into heavy industry it goes into
the transportation sector
you can make fuels out of it like
methanol or ammonia
you can put it straight into the grid
there's all kinds of stuff you can do
and in the in the context of that i want
to
head back to something melissa just
mentioned um
if you replace an existing
power plant of some kind with a hydrogen
plant
you should have no pollution with it of
any kind
so you should be able to do that in a
way that's fair and equitable and to do
that requires union labor
so you should be able to do it in a way
which is good paying jobs that
are long-term jobs right so so there's a
way in which hydrogen can be brought
forward that's smart and equitable and
real
and we'll see if we do that or not dr
freeman why isn't that happening now is
because the technology's too new or
just existing just the resistance of
change in general
there's a couple of reasons but uh first
and foremost there
is there's no market aligned policy
it goes back to where i started right so
we have a production tax credit for
solar and wind we have an investment tax
credit for solar and when we got nothing
for hydrogen
so who's going to make it to make zero
carbon hydrogen today cost between two
times and ten times more
than hydrogen that emits who's going to
make it
we need to create market aligning
incentives to do it and that could be a
clean energy standard a clean
electricity standard
that could be a production tax credit
for the low carbon hydrogen
there's all kinds of things you could do
but but you got to start getting the
market apparatus going
okay you also need to do things like
replace truck engines with fuel cells
it'll take some time it'll take some
money to do that you need to have
fueling stations where people can get
hydrogen so
there's i could spend the whole rest of
this program talking about that i won't
there's good reasons why not but but
that's something i'm excited about
because the technology's gotten cheap
enough
and the ambition's gotten high enough
that we're starting to get alignment
between
the ambition and the price and that's
that's when exciting stuff starts to
happen and at this point i just hope
that
the crazy people on both ends of the
dumbbell don't shrink it away
um because in fact there's a lot of
heavy lifting to be done in the middle
and it looks like we're getting to that
point
the other thing i'm excited about is co2
removal
so we have that residual emission stack
that we can't get rid of
okay and for the past 20 years i've been
hearing people say don't even talk about
that because if we talk about it we'll
we'll stop
reducing emissions well guess what like
we didn't reduce emissions
we're stuffed we still need to do this
people didn't want to talk about carbon
capture because it would give people an
excuse to keep emitting carbon
carbon excuse me that's like saying the
existence of diet coke means nobody will
lose weight it's a ridiculous argument
but
you know there you go but but uh be that
as it may
uh we it's now we have we realize that
we are going to overshoot if we want to
have a justin verdin world
we're going to have to do a lot of co2
removal to get to zero again
to melissa's point net zero is
clarifying zero means nothing so if you
make
anything anywhere you have to remove
that amount
and when you get into big scale co2
removal
we need trees we need soils we need
direct air capture devices which i
am excited about we need biohydrogen
with ccs
we need carbon mineralization we need
mangroves
we need all of the above on that too
there's just not enough tonnage
with any one of those things you can't
get the 10 billion tons a year we're
gonna need
with just one thing so it's all of the
above all over again
and it gives us i think an opportunity
to be generous with each other again
to say we know we need to spend money we
know we need to try lots of stuff
we know one of us alone is not going to
do the job
so let's all work together and do this
incredibly important thing
and we've seen mark carney at the bank
of england now
launch this transparency thing for
carbon offsets we've seen a bunch of
banks start getting into this
we've seen tech companies like google
and amazon and microsoft and apple start
getting into the co2 removal business
that's exciting so this is a very
non-scientist question or maybe possibly
naive questions there's technology up
there where
let's call a device or something sucks
carbon out of the air like how does that
work where can it go like i'm just more
curious of the implementation of
that technology that's probably that
technology was invented in the 30s for
submarines like we've had it for a long
time
what's exciting now is we're starting to
scale it so there's a handful of
companies companies like climax and
carbon engineering
that will do that which will build the
plant and suck the co2 out of the air
and store it
in the deep geosphere forever good so
we didn't have companies 10 years ago
now we got companies that's a step
forward
and right now the technology is ballpark
four to six hundred bucks a ton which is
too much to pay
great we know how to reduce costs
that's one thing we do know how to do
you put money into innovation you make
market aligning policies you deploy a
bunch of stuff and the costs go down
like we've done that with everything for
leds for batteries for flat screen tvs
like we know the recipe for that one and
now we're starting to see
voluntary markets come together and
companies like microsoft
put money into it and companies like
carbon direct organizing their thinking
and companies like mckinsey recommending
to governments that they change the way
they think
like that's like you're starting to see
bits of the ecosystem come together in a
useful way
and you can put that anywhere in the
world you can put it in the north slope
of alaska
you can put it in the gulf of mexico you
can put it in abu dhabi
you need zero carbon heat you need zero
carbon electricity
as long as you got those things you can
do direct air capture
in the new york context believe it or
not the building codes can help
because there's a new civic code that
says
all buildings have to be net zero by
2025.
which is very very challenging and if
they don't
they have to pay 477 a ton
that's enough money to start paying for
stuff and that is where look governments
can't create
value but they can they can align
incentives they can incentivize value
right and that's kind of where we need
to go david what is exciting you
i want to talk about culture right i
think what excites me
is i think what julio mentioned of like
people start to are starting to see the
art of the possible and clean energy and
that really excites me and i think
um what julio mentioned of like you know
10 years ago solar was 10 times more
expensive
you know wind was three times more
expensive right and when you
when you like see that on a scientist
projection well you're like well
okay maybe we'll see right when that's
backward looking
that's a big deal right and i think
people start to get
excited about what the world can look
like not what it looks like today i
think you know we've been
we've been spoiled by moore's law in the
technology world that
you know things just get smaller and
cheaper over time when it comes to
semiconductors
what people have shown is that like the
same process of like
you double the scale you reduce cost
like that doesn't just apply to
semiconductors
right and i think what part of the we
just have to start
and i think there's so many people now
getting in this game and getting excited
about it
that it peop you know big companies are
listening governments are listening
things are starting to change is it
happening fast enough no
but i think part of that is our
opportunity right for those that are in
the space
to be in it and to hopefully do really
well from it i would say too
you know i think your point around short
change being a four-letter word
i think when it's imposed no matter who
it is it's a four-letter
word right when you feel like you have a
control of your own world in control of
your own change and can benefit from
that change
it's the most exciting thing in the
world and i would point to
what california's done with low carbon
fuel standard you know and like the
growth and renewable energy credits that
have happened as a result of
for farmers that have pig farms and cow
farms like
you go up and down iowa wisconsin
illinois indiana
there's not a cow farm in a pig farm
that hasn't been knocked on their door
like 20 times
because it is a gold rush right now and
those guys are making a ton of money
on basically taking the farts from their
cows
their cows and their pigs and doing
something with it and then selling that
gas
into the california market that the that
the big companies over there have to pay
for
like they are making a ton of money you
got a lot of farmers in the midwest who
made a ton of money from wind and solar
like that change is exciting right
that's why you get i think really
positive change in those communities
when it's imposed it's negative right
and this i think clean energy is a way
for entrepreneurs to benefit
one thing you recommend the average
human to start doing that if everybody
was doing we'd be in a better place
i think what julia said resonated with
me like learn first care second
um learn what in your community in your
business
in your you know day-to-day life you can
how you can impact and some of it you
know for some people is just gonna be
electing the right people calling your
senator you're
you know we live in a representative
democracy we have the ability to change
what happens in policy but for a lot of
people like their business can make
change right and and i think
what we talked about with efficiency
like putting leds is a benefit thing
like it there's a huge amount of
benefits not just mentioned energy
efficiency like
it generates more light makes life it
makes world it's safer
right it makes it look better for your
customers so like
simple stuff right done in aggregate i
think can change the world
and i think that as people start to
learn and then care
um i really like that as a framework dr
lot what would you say
i mean i think it stems off what david
just said which is realizing like this
is your health we're talking
about and this is your health right now
we're talking about this is important
this matters right now
this isn't some mystical thing in the
future and so you know we've got so many
layers of government that we can say hey
you represent me
this is important to me and we need to
act on this
and with our collective voices we can do
a lot
like that's how policy gets done is when
we say okay across aisles across
conversations like we want this this is
important to us
let's do it so people get so consumed
with dc and dc is important
but so is your local city hall right
probably more important i agree with you
um and dr freeman
close with you the short snippy answer
if there's one thing people can do they
can vote
please go god damn vote vote god damn it
we need we need voters
we got issues but i'm with you like
we're still at 40
voting like perhaps we can do a little
better than that you know
but but really the the most important
thing for people to do right now more
than anything else eve
like i still like learn and care like
that's a good thing to do
learn that 77 of americans don't have
rooftops so they can't do rooftop solar
like that's a good thing to learn
before you care about how to fix that um
but but the thing that i
want people to do more than anything
else like be
generous and the person i'm channeling
these days more than anybody else is
yoda
i'm really trying to channel yoda in
everything i do these days
and my favorite yoda quote is fear leads
to anger
anger leads to hate and hate leads to
suffering
that's no way to fix this problem folks
we can't fix it by being more angry and
more shrill
we got to be generous and work together
to fix the problems
and if we listen and if we're generous
we can get there
well that is there's nothing more
fitting than closing this conversation
with a quote from yoda
so thank you i think my takeaway here
is that the future of energy is that
there is no future unless we figure out
the present of energy
in its own way like we don't start doing
things now um
the future can be very exciting but we
need to do something collectively now so
look you all are so impressive um
i was on pins and needles this entire
conversation just trying to keep up with
the brain power on this zoom call um and
on this podcast so
from by my heart thank you for joining
gang speaks the future of energy
talk soon y'all it's our pleasure thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
you